le roman de Loula documentaire réalisé
par José Bourgarel ou le portrait d'un
homme vous venez de le voir au destin
réellement extraordinaire dont le
parcours syndical et politique aura
aussi épousé l'histoire de son pays
pendant tris/4 de siècle voilà un an
Loula a été donc réélu pour la troisième
fois à la tête du Brésil pour quel bilan
retour gagnant nous allons en débattre
maintenant en compagnie de nos invité
présent sur ce plateau de débat dooc en
commençant par vous Christophe Ventura
bienvenue vous êtes direct directeur de
recherche à l'IRIS l'institut de
recherche internationale et et
stratégique en charge de son programme
Amérique latine Caraïbe et vous êtes
l'auteur de géopolitique de l'Amérique
latine 40 fiches pour comprendre le
monde édité chez herol globert serésino
est également avec nous bienvenue vous
êtes sociologue co-président de
l'association autre Brésil qu'on
retrouve avec plaisir sur ce plateau une
association fondée mainant voilà 15 ans
et qui s'est donné pour but de déc
les enjeux sociétaux brésiliens pour le
public francophone et puis enfin avec
nous Édouard Dorian CIPEL bienvenue vous
êtes ancien député socialiste de saine
et Marne porte-parole aujourd'hui de
territoire de progrès vous êtes
originaire du Brésil de quel région
Porto Allegre pour nous situer un tout
petit peu pour n sud du Brésil ouis
quasiment à la finin l'état de Rous don
la capitale est Porto Allègre se situe
si vous voulez dans la à la frontière de
l'Argentine de l'Uruguay et du Paraguay
voilà je suis un garçon du Sud du Sud du
Sud Christophe Ventura il y a il y a
tout juste un an Loula était donc réélu
pour la troisème fois à la tête de son
pays on a on a revécu tout ça à travers
ce ce film il avait été réélu avec moins
de 51 % des suffrages c'était
extrêmement juste face à bolsonaro
Victoire étriqué victoire tout de même
avec un pays à la sortie de cette
élection extrêmement polarisé entre
partisan de l'un et partisan de l'autre
est-ce que cette polarisation a un temps
soi peu réussi à se résorber euh au sein
du Brésil aujourd'hui bah elle s'est
résorbée dans une certaine mesure
puisque Loula a gagné de peu comme vous
dites il a aussi gagné sans majorité au
Congrès brésilien avec un pays continent
où de nombreux États sont restés aux
mains du bolsonarisme ou des alliés du
bolsonarisme mais en fait les événements
qui se sont précipités on s'en souvient
en janvier 2023 avec les émeutes
surrection de l'extrême droite
brésilienne ont en fait créé un
sentiment qui de de corps autour de
Loula de tous ceux qui restent quand
même attachés disons au système
démocratique dans ce pays indépendamment
de ou parceil il faut rappeler hein et
vous le faites le 8 janvier 2023 c'était
en janvier dernier des
manifestants à Brasilia la capitale du
Brésil ont investi à la fois le palais
présidentiel le Parlement la Cour
suprême he c'est cette fameuse place des
trois pouvoirs et on a craint tout
simplement pour l'avenir de cette
démocratie brésilienne à un moment tout
à fait et du coup ça a joué plutôt en
faveur de Loula dans le sens où même pas
mal de ses adversaires politiqu ont dû
se positionner par rapport à ces
événements qui pouvaient être une
rupture et du coup ça a rendu la
démocratie brésilienne à la fois de
retour mais opérationnel fonctionnel
donc Loula aujourd'hui incarne une forme
de retour de la légitimité démocratique
dissons stabilisé dans un pays où la
polarisation n'a pas disparu parce que
il y a pas d'état de grâce pour Loula
depuis qu'il a été élu mais il y a un
fonctionnement qui est plus normal une
démocratie qui est plus apaisée qui est
plus opérationnelle et ce qui s'est
polarisé aussi et ce qui peut-être a
pris le pas sur la situation intérieure
brésilienne c'est plutôt le contexte
international depuis que lui a été élu
et aujourd'hui bah Loula il fonctionne
dans ce double système de contrainte
alors cette situation politique euh elle
est importante à à à comprendre il a
fallu stabiliser cette majorité très
très hétéroclite hein le le cabinet
gouvernemental compte aujourd'hui 38
membres issus de 11 partis politiques
différents avec seulement 23 femmes hein
d'ailleurs au passage alors certes il a
une une majorité à la Chambre des
députés 374 élus euh sur 513 députés et
puis a aussi une large majorité au Sénat
mais avec une majorité qui va de
l'extrême gauche jusqu'au partis
conservateur et même des partis qui
avaient soutenu bolsonaro auparavant
est-ce qu'il peut euh euh diriger ce
pays dans ses conditions avec une telle
coalition dans les mois qui viennent
est-ce que c'est pas un problème pour
pour pour cette 3è présidence sou là bah
c'est un problème mais c'est aussi le
fait que le Brésil a toujours vécu des
présidents son peu sur la base des
négociations il n'a jamais eu des vraies
majorités pour le présidents depuis la
redémocratisation parce que du fait
d'avoir ce nombre de partis assez
conséquent au Parlement brésilien toute
décision menée par l'exécutif est
négocié au cas par cas presque presque
au cas par cas et quon on voit le nombre
de de ministres qui ont été mis des
partis proches de bolsonaro on voit
aussi que cette majorité de Loula elle
est très instable et c'est à chaque
nouvelle votation au Parlement à chaque
nouvelle décision au Parlement qui cette
majorité est testée au fur et à mesure
on va voir en prochain test là parce que
loua vient de mettre en vetau à la loi
qui vient de sortir du Parlement qui
attaquait les territoires autochtones au
Brésil il a mis en vetto sur cette loi
en considérant que c'est
inconstitutionnel et ce vetau doit être
voté par les parlements par l'Assemblée
nationale dans les prochains dans les
prochains jours et là on va voir la
capacité de garder cette majorité de Lou
là il est déjà en train de négocier en
disant bon on va donner on peut parci on
peut par là mais ça montre à quel point
cette majorité est complètement en
stable on va voir si sa capacité de
négociateur qui a été mis en avant
évidemment dans ce documentaire
concilier l'inconciliable voilà ce qui
arrivé à faire lou là jusqu'à maintenant
on va voir si ça va être le cas avec
avec cette majorité é aussi hétérquite
qu'elle soit il n'y a pas eu d'état de
grâce a dit Christophe Ventura vous vous
êtes d'accord avec ça il y a pas eu
d'état de grâce pour cette 3e président
celou non et vous savez je crois que la
grâce manque y compris au football
brésilien donc ce que nous vivons au
Brésil c'est
une réalité politique très dure et je
crois qu'il faut saluer le Brésil le
peuple brésilien parce que la victoire
de Loula elle est salutaire pour deux
raisons
euh d'abord parce que elle met un terme
à l'expérience bolsonaro une expérience
d'extrême droite avec un président
brésilien bolsonaro qui était
nostalgique je crois qu'il faut le
rappeler de la dictature militaire et la
victoire de de loua débarrasse le Brésil
de cette très mauvaise expérience
dangereuse mais elle est aussi le signe
de la vitalité démocratique du Brésil la
victoire de Loula est le symbole de la
victoire de la démocratie brésilienne
des institutions brésiliennes parce
qu'il pesaent vraiment des menaces de
triche euh euh de coup d'état plus ou
moins
euh préparé par bolsonaro et ses
soutiens et ce qui a résister en réalité
à travers la victoire de douas c'est la
possibilité d'alternance et c'est on l'a
vu y compris avec les attaques sur la
place du trois pouvoir des images qui
rappelaient ce qui s'était passé au
Capitol aux États-Unis après la défaite
de Trump et on a a vu qu'en
réalité les institutions démocratiques
du Brésil tenaient bon et je crois que
c'est ça je crois pard là la victoire de
loua elle-même que j'ai j'ai soutenu
mais c'est la victoire de la démocratie
et ça c'est très positif pour un pays
qui a redécouvert la démocratie en
1988 après près de 25 ans de dictature
militaire donc voilà je crois que c'est
ça c'est la victoire d'abord d'un esprit
d'apaise
et la victoire surtout d'institutions
démocratiques fortes parce que le peuple
brésilien en grande majorité est attaché
à ces institutions démocratiques alors
vous parliez de bolsonaro et c'est
normal bolsonaro ent-etemps a été
condamné à 8 ans d'inéligligibilité pour
abus de pouvoir politique et usage indu
des moyens de de communication bolsonaro
donc logiquement suite à cette décision
du tribunal supérieur électoral
brésilien ne pourra pas se présenter à
la présidentielle de 2026 je vous
propose de revoir un court très court ex
du documentaire nous sommes en pleine
campagne
présidentielle au moment de la dernière
élection de
Loula no século XX a gente criç que DMIR
Pinho
de qui prett encore et toujours de
donner à manger à chacun au Brésil il a
aujourd'hui environ selon mes chiffres
33 millions de Brésiliens qui ne mangent
pas à leur fin sur une population de 215
millions de Brésiliens c'est environ 15
% de de personnes qui ne mangent pas à
leur faim ça c'était sa promesse numéro
1 ça a toujours été sa promesse en
réalité dès sa première élection que
chacun mange à sa faim au Brésil on en
est encore là au Brésil hein est-ce
qu'il a tenu promesse sur ce plan depuis
maintenant allez 9 mois he qu'il a pris
vraiment les reennes du pays c'est trop
tôt pour le dire sur la question de la
fin en tant que tel mais il est clair
que Loula a récupéré un Brésil en miette
après le passage de bolsonaro le passage
du covid-19 et les effet à de long terme
de la crise économique internationale de
2008 puis après arrivé rapidement la
crise de la guerre en Ukraine le Brésil
est en Miet il y a les 15 % de de
problème de fin que vous avez cité mais
si on prend d'autres indicateurs comme
la pauvreté on arrive quasiment au tiers
des Brésiliens qui sont en état de
pauvreté on arrive à des niveaux
d'inégalité record et cetera et cetera
donc Loula récupéré un pays en
souffrance ça il y a pas de doute
là-dessus et donc il est clair que son
programme intérieur il tient à peu près
en trois points c'est des politiques qui
visent effectivement à lutter contre la
pauvreté la plus grande pauvreté et les
inégalités sociales un une politique qui
vise à développer le pays en fait c'est
ça son idée et à le réindustrialiser
c'est ça les trois axes de son de son
programme aujourd'hui je pense qu'au
niveau intérieur c'est trop tôt pour
tirer un bilan même si ce qu'on peut
dire globalement depuis janvier 2023
c'est que la situation économique s'est
sensiblement améliorée dans le sens où
même le le Fond Monétaire International
la Banque mondiale ou d'autres
organisations atteste bien que il y a
une un regain une reprise économique au
Brésil de la croissance générale
générale que les exportations
brésiliennes sont euh en en bonne santé
et c'est une des conséquences d'ailleurs
euh secondaires si j'ose dire de la
guerre de en
Ukraine exportation
alimentairegéti voilàctement donc ça va
plutôt mieux la question c'est que c'est
encore un petit peu tôt pour savoir si
ça ça se traduit par une redistribution
accrue en fait des fruits de la richesse
auprès des populations mais il y a eu
des décisions qui ont été prises en
matière de relèvement des revenus des
des minimas sociaux enfin les
équivalents au Brésil qui touchent plus
de gens qui ont été élargis et qu' ont
disons été rehaussé aussi en fonction de
l'inflation que connu connaî le pays
donc on peut penser que la situation
s'améliore un peu mais structurellement
les problèmes du Brésil sont toujours
présents alors vous vou les régir l'un
et l'autre alors on va commencer par
vous ensuite je vous la parole en effet
ces chiffres sont des chiffres des
encore de la période bolsonaro tu vois
c'est des chiffres de l'année 2022 quand
bolsonaro était encore au pouvoir donc
on je suis d'accord avec Christophe
qu'on n'est pas encore en mesure de dire
à quel quel état on vit aujourd'hui et
loua tout à fait mé de nouvelles
politiques bon repris des politiques
pour garantir les minimum sociaux et
augmenter les salaires minimum au Brésil
c'est une vraie politique qu'il a mené
pendant ses 8 ans de mandat précédent et
qu'il a remis sur le sur la scène et il
a relancé le plans les packs qu'on
appelle au Brésil les plans de
d'accélération et croissance le problèm
c'est que ces packs se basent sur de
l'infrastructure pour pour
venir aider justement l'exportation des
matières primières donc c'est de
secteurs économiques qui qui ne sont pas
d'un point de vue de la population des
travailleurs les meilleurs les meilleurs
secteurs économiques pour garantir une
stabilité économique dans le long terme
et le plans d'accélération économique
visent à forcer les infrastructures ce
qui va créer énormément de de de travail
dans les BTP pour les infrastructures
mais sont des travails précaires qui
n'ont pas tendance à durer dans les
temps donc il va à nouveau essayer la
même politique entre guillemets qu'il a
essayé donc il a fait dans les h
premières années qui va générer quoi de
l'emploi mais de l'emploi précaire à
basse salaire et que du coup va
probablement générer les mêmes
situations qui nous ont amené en 2013
tout de même si je vous ai bien entendu
repioché en quelque sorte dans les
politiques notamment les politiques
sociales quiavait déjà mis en œuvre à
l'occasion de ses deux premières
présidences grosso modo les structures
de de sa politique c'est un peu la même
gr vous
savez loua a connu la fin ouais on l'a
très bien vu dans ce documentaire lola a
souffert de la fin c'est un petit
garçon je vais le dire comme ça
misérable d'une famille
nombreuse misérable du nordest brésilien
qui a fui ce nordest exode vers saintpul
où il a grandi ou est devenu ouvrier
syndicaliste et le parcours que l'on
connaît il sait ce que c'est moi j'ai
pas connu la fin mais lui se rappelle de
est- ce que vous êtes en train de N dire
c'est pourquoi il a les larmes aux yeux
et vous savez moi aussi me donne un
petit peu les larmes aux yeux parce que
autant j'ai pas connu la fin j'ai vécu
les 10 premières années de ma vie au
Brésil à porte Allègre mais tout petit
brésilien même quand il vient des
catégories favorisées il fait
l'expérience de ceux qui à côté de lui
ont FA et je peux vous dire c'est très
choquant on finit par hélas un petit peu
s'habituer parce que voilà mais moi j'ai
toujours eu ce sentiment et quand je
suis arrivé en France j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait des cantines scolaires pas
gratuites mais quand même à des prix
raisonnables et aujourd'hui vous avez
encore effectivement des enfants qui
souffrent de la faim ou de la très
mauvaise alimentation quand vous avez un
président de la
République encore cette fois mais dès sa
première élection qui fait campagne en
disant moi mon programme c'est
d'apporter trois repas par jour à tous
les petits brésiliens qui le dit avec la
force de celui qui a encore dans ses
tripes la douleur terrible et
insupportable de la fin je crois que
c'est un grand homme politique qui sait
de quoi il parle et ceux à qui il
s'adresse au nord de Rio qui vote très
majoritairement pour lui il suffit de
voir la carte on parle de la division de
la fracturation du pays c'est un peu
binaire c'est au-dessus de Rio là où
sont essentiellement les pauvres ça vote
lou là parce que ils savent qu'il vient
aussi de là où ces populations viennent
qu'il connaît leurs problèmes et qui
donc il a un minimum de crédibilité et
il a fait ça dans son premier mandat les
trois petits repas par jour pour tous
les petits brésiliens
puis familia ce be sa famille ce revenu
de base on va dire les choses comme ça
pe oui c'est ça et c'est des problèmes
qu'on ne connaît plus en France et en
Europe même si on a des problèmes de de
de sous-alimentation pour une partie de
notre population c'est nouveau et et je
pense qu'il faut être alerté là-dessus
mais moi il me donne ses accent de ces
hommes qui en France comme jores se
bataient pour les minimums vitaux pour
les droits élémentaires des gens ça
c'est lou là c'est ce qu'il représente
et au-delà de toute la géopolitique
qu'il peut faire de ce qui symbolise
aussi pour plein de combat ça je crois
que c'est sa marque de fabrique cette
attention pour un pays où il y a encore
des enfants et des familles qui peuvent
mourir de faim alors que nous sommes
l'un des au Brésil l'un des plus grands
exportateurs de matière agricole
alimentaire céréales ou viande et c'est
pas supportable il faut que le Brésil
qui est un grand pays règle enfin ça et
je pense que Lola est peut-être la
personne qui est la plus sensible et la
plus à même de le comprendre et de le
mettre en œuvre autre dossier sur lequel
on attendait ce retour de Loula alors
pas seulement au Brésil mais aussi sur
le plan international c'est bien sûr
l'Amazonie hein ce poumon que représente
l'Amazonie au sein du monde aujourd'hui
environnemental nous avons réduit la
déforestation de 42 % lors de ces 7
premiers mois de l'année a affirmé la la
ministre brésilienne de l'environnement
qui s'appelle Marina Silva euh là aussi
il a pris les les les choses au main il
a inversé ce qu'avait été la politique
de bolsonaro concernant l'Amazonie on
peut dire les choses comme ça disons
qu'il a mis un coup d'arrêt assez net
disons au laisser aller intégral j'en
dire fondamentaliste qu'incarnet le
bolsonaris par rapport à la
déforestation pour que les
téléspectatrices et les téléspectateurs
nous comprennent 60% % de l'Amazonie sur
le territoire brésilien et et l'Amazonie
ce territoire là représente à peu près
un/ers du territoire brésilien on parle
de ça et la politique de Loula c'est
finalement de là aussi de remettre en
place ce que ce qu'avait soigneusement
détricoté finalement bolsonaro avant lui
c'est-à-dire tous les systèmes de
surveillance de police aussi et tous les
systèmes et les financements qui
permettent la surveillance et le le
ralentissement même le coup d'arrêt
c'est ce ce à quoi il s'engage dans un
premier temps Loula depuis qu'il a pris
des fonctions en janvier 2023 de la
déforestation dite illégale de la forêt
amazonienne c'est ça qui a déjà été
disons côérisé par Loula grâce à la
relance des programmes des
administrations de surveillance et
cetera et c'est ça qui a donné les
chiffres dont vous venez de parler qui
la reprise en main de ces
administrations aussi SEM oui la reprise
en main leur refinancement parce que en
fait bolsonaro avant avait laissé tout
ça formellement existé mais il les avait
tués par inanition si vous voulez
c'estàd qu'il les avait tué par il avait
coupé les budgets c'est aussi si simple
que ça il avait coupé les budgets les
financements et donc plus personne
pouvait travailler il y avait plus de
surveillance plus de police plus rien
donc tout le monde faisait ce qu'il
voulait et puis lui il avait un discours
pour allez-y allez-y brûler la forêt
pour et cetera pour vous enrichir bref
Loula a remis les choses en place donc
la déforestation légal et ben l'objectif
c'est zéro et puis dans un deuxième
temps il ancéforestation zéro voilà
l'objectif mais aussi ce sera
déforestation zéro tout court c'est un
objectif mais ça c'est une transition en
tout cas c'est comme ça qu'il la
présente mais en réalité L là n'est pas
sur l'idée qu'il faut ne plus toucher à
l'Amazonie et qu'il faudrait qu'elle
devienne un bien commun de l'humanité
comme par exemple Emmanuel Macron
l'avait souhaité à un moment donné c'est
pas la position de Loula non plus c'est
d'ailleurs la position de pas beaucoup
d'acteurs politiques au Brésil
l'Amazonie est vécu comme l'ADN de
l'identité du modèle de la société
brésilienne par tous les Brésiliens ils
en veulent la souveraineté absolue et
elle est indissociablement lié la
question de l'Amazonie la question des
ressources et du développement du pays
donc lou là a une approche qui est
développ mentaliste comme on dit
c'està-dire il veut quand même utiliser
les ressources de l'Amazonie pour
participer au développement économique
du pays mais sur disons une trajectoire
qui est régulée qui fait l'objet d'une
réflexion politique d'une planification
de d'une protection des terre indigène
ou une négociation avec eux pour pas si
vous voulez qu'on soit dans la brutalité
du laisser faire par rapport à ce sujet
mais les projets de Loula pour
l'Amazonie c'est quand même des projets
qui visent à si vous voulez utiliser les
ressources qu'elle contient pour le
développement du pays un mot assez court
hein si vous voulez rajouter quelque
chose il a des projets assez assez
dangereux par exemple aujourd'hui il il
a un énorme projet d'exploitation du
pétrole sur l'embouchure de la du fleuve
Amazone qui est mé par l'OUA par le
gouvernement de Loula qui met en danger
du coup le justement cette faune et
cette flore justement à la sortie du
fleuve Amazon il y a un énorme projet de
construction d' d'une route de train de
au milieu d' liant les centre-ouest du
Brésil au nord du pays et il y a des
projets pour refaire de de autoroute au
milieu de la forêt amazonenne qui
passent par des territoires autochtones
par des réserves environnementales donc
là on voit la la contradiction de ce
gouvernements là justement qui est qui
monte la rampe du du palais présidentiel
avec Raoni à ses côtés mais qu'
aujourd'hui lance des projets qui vont
passer sur des territoires autochtones
on va avancer un tout petit peu il nous
reste une dizaine de minutes et et je
voulais parler maintenant de sur le plan
et du Brésil bien entendu sur le plan
international Loula s'est rendu dans 21
pays hein depuis qu' il a repris la
direction du Brésil a rencontré plus
d'une cinquantaine de chefs de
gouvernement il est très actif au sein
du Brix alors le brick c'est le Brésil
Russie Inde Chine et Afrique du Sud euh
je ne sais pas si on pourrait dire que
ce sont les nouveaux pays non aligné
c'est peut-être le ce débat hein qu'il
faut avoir est-ce que le Brésil est de
retour sur la la scène internationale le
Brésil est de retour c'est le ça c'est
le slogan de Loula qu'il Martelle depuis
des mois qu'il a repris le pouvoir au
Brésil oui et la politique étrangère est
l'une des marques de fabrique de
l'identité politique de Loula de tous
ces gouvernements et effectivement
bolsonaro s'était refermé sur lui-même
et n'avait aucune crédibilité à la
chaîne internationale aujourd'hui Loula
revient avec euh le retour du respect du
Brésil sur la scène internationale et le
retour d'une action euh c'est un peu
rondonant mais active d'une politique
active à l'échelle internationale
l'Amazonie c'est intéressant envie dire
tout Asie mute tout as tous les sujets
sur lesquels le Brésil comme une
puissance en développement je sais plus
c'est les 6e ou 7e puissance économique
puissance en devenir elle veut prendre
sa part de responsabilité dans les
affaires du monde et dire aussi ce qu'il
en pense d'abord on est concerné la
prendre où sa place avec le brésilce
qu'il est non anigné aujourd'hui l comme
il l'a longtemps été hein il a repris la
les mêmes recettes le même position sur
certains sujets il peut essayer de ne
pas être aligné c'est-à-dire aux
États-Unis d'Amérique ce qui explique
certaines positions un peu
compliqué notamment sur la situation
entre la Russie et l'Ukraine la guerre
et et et et aussi peut-être avec le
conflit entre maintenant Israël et le
ramas le Brésil avec Loula aujourd'hui i
préside le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
hein c'est une présidence tournante
c'est le tour du Brésil c'est Président
c'est président en ce moment même par
l'ou là ça c'est un premier
point deuxième point bientôt le Brésil
va accueillir et c'est pas un hasard un
G20 donc ce sont des symboles par
lesquels Loula montre sa volonté de
prendre part de recevoir et d'accueillir
des forums et des sommets
internationaux la question de l'Amazonie
elle est à la fois une question
intérieure parce que en effet le Brésil
défendra coûte que cûte la souveraineté
sur son territoire amazonien mais veut
assumer aussi sa responsabilité dans la
lutte pour le climat contre le
réchauffement climatique et l'Amazonie
joue un rôle fondamental Loula se
servira de ce point d'appui de
l'Amazonie parce que c'est un problème
concret et en même temps va essayer à
partir de là de poser les jalons d'une
politique et d'une lutte en faveur du
climat oui c'est le retour du Brésil ça
veut pas dire qu'on sera tout le temps
d'accord avec eux mais moi je crois que
euh c'est important c'est le premier
président brésilien qui a une ambition
et une volonté de peser sur les affaires
international à la hauteur de ce que
représente aujourd'hui le Brésil sur la
scène internationale c'est un retour qui
à mon avis est salué parce que le Brésil
doit être un partenaire et un acteur je
dirais très important des enjeux qui
viennent il y a ce fameux Brix hein euh
que j'ai évoqué euh Brésil Russie Inde
Chine Afrique du Sud qui pose quand même
un petit problème du côté occidental
parce que euh ça représente euh tout de
même euh 40 % du de la richesse mondiale
euh plus de la moitié de la population
mondiale c'est hein sur le papier c'est
c'est considérable euh on s'interroge
tout de même est-ce qu'il euh s'alie
d'une certaine manière avec d'une part
la Chine et la Russie qui sont eux dans
un bloc clairement
antioccidental c'est quoi le
positionnement de Loula là et du Brésil
euh au sein de ce brixs alors c'est un
des cfondateurs déjà Loula est très fier
d'avoir été euh aux affaires lorsque les
bricks ont été créés à la fin des années
2000 2009-20 c'est un des fondateurs des
bricks le Brésil c'est un pays qui a
quelques positions fortes au sein des
bricks parce que il y a les bricks en
tant que tel puis y a la banque des
bricks aussi qui est désormais présidée
par Dilma Roussef l'ancienne présidente
qui avait été destituée brutalement on
s'en souvient en 2016 elle est la
présidente de la banque des bricks donc
bricks qui vont s'élargir d'ailleurs à
partir du 1er janvier 2024 avec six
nouveaux membres dont un nouveau
sudaméricain qui est normalement
l'Argentine si tout se passe comme ça
devrait se passer alors même l'Arabie
Saoudite et l'Iran qui frappe à la porte
sont peut-être des partenaires plus
déliquat à gérer et ça ça nous emmène à
votre première question quelle est la
position du Brésil le Brésil sa position
en fait vis avis de la Chine et de la
Russie alors elle est assez simple la
position du Brésil de Loula en tout cas
c'est que la ligne de Loula c'est que le
Brésil parle à tout le monde sans
exclusive et ne s'affilie pas à des
logiques disons idéologiques et cetera
donc c'est en fait une forme de
nonalignement mais qui est un
nonalignement disons qui est actif
pourquoi actif parce que le la stratégie
de Loula dans un monde qui est de plus
en plus chaotique qui est de plus en
plus polarisé qui est de plus en plus
tendu à tous les niveaux et cetera et
bien c'est une logique qui vise à
affirmer tout simplement l'intérêt
national du Brésil et sa souveraineté en
en toutes chos et donc Brésil Loula
refuse de parler à certains et pas à
d'autres il pense même à avoir justement
peut-être cette spécificité sur le plan
international d'avoir de bonnes
relations avec tout le monde et d'être
utile à tout le monde pour ça et de
pouvoir être dans des dossiers X Y
pouvoir jouer un rôle de médiation ou de
facilitation d'apaisement des tensions
et des conflits c'est ça la stratégie
dou là mais derrière c'est l'intérêt
national du Brésil qui compte que veut
le Brésil il veut devenir une puissance
globale sur un certain nombre de Dossi
ces dossiers c'est la transition
énergétique c'est les questions
alimentaires il ne veut pas jouer
simplement latino-américain il veut
jouer global le Brésil donc il il veut
s'affirmer il veut affirmer ses intérêts
et pour cela il a des moyens une
diplomatie Act qui est très
multilatérale c'est vrai que Loula en
2023 est à la présidence du Conseil s
des Nations Unies ça a été dit le Brésil
va présider le G20 en
2023-2024 en 2025 il dirigera les bricks
et aussi ila la COP 30 à BM en Amazonie
donc disons la séquence multilatérale et
de projection internationale pour le
Brésil est très avantageuse par rapport
à la politique de Loula ouais c'est
c'est un adepte de la multipolarité
c'est pas un adepte d'un monde divisé en
deux de blocs et ça se voit il a
commencé le Brésil a commencé déjà à
négocier avec la Chine en utilisant pas
le dollar en utilisant le yen et le Réal
brésilien pour essayer de créer
justement d'autres lignes économiques
aussi pour essayer de jouer dans ce dans
ce monde aujourd'hui qui malheureusement
n'est pas en train de le suivre tout
àmute comme comme on essait parce que la
situation bsonaro c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui n'a pas condamné l'invasion
euh de l'Ukraine par la Russie et qui a
condamné les sanctions internationales
c'est on voit ces positionns qui sont
avec l'œil le regard occidental
aujourd'hui un peu difficile à à
comprendre quand on connaît ce parcours
de Loula qu'on l'a revu dans ce
documentaire on justement c'est je pense
que c'est une belle traduction de ces
parcours de Loula Loula c'était toujours
un homme de négociation c'est jamais été
un homme de confrontation directe et
c'était dit dans les documentaires il
parle à tout le monde à la sortie de la
dictature et la démocratie il négocie
dans un certain dans certaines mesure
aussi avec si c'était par exemple on
brisola à la sortie de la dictature
militaire il n' aurait pas de
négociation avec les militaires les
élites économiques qui appuyaient les
militaires n là il s'est permettait ce
type de négociation donc c'est la marque
Loula qui perdure si vous avez bien
compris une minute ça sera la fin oui
Loula est un politique pure un grand
politique et la politique c'est d'abord
la discussion la politique c'est la
négociation à partir d'un rapport de
force c'est une situation donnée mais le
grand politique ou la grande politique
c'est celui qui est capable de de
trouver des solutions en fonction des
rapports de force pour défendre ses
intérêts et trouver des compromis loua
est de cette nature euh euh euh et donc
je crois qu'il va pleinement jouer cela
hein la politique c'est d'abord la
création politique y compris sur les
affaires géopolitique le Brésil va comme
toutes les nations défendre ses intérêts
mais je crois que Loula a quand même une
vision en effet globale il plaide pour
un monde meilleur il sait d'où il vient
on parlait de la question climatique qui
est nouvelle avec toutes les
contradictions les antag onisme les
tensions qu' peut y avoir sur la
question de l'Amazonie on l'a vu tout à
l'heure comment concilier intérêt de
développement et intérêt climatique et
puis je crois que l'OUA aura aussi à
cœur de porter un autre sujet la lutte à
l'échelle mondiale contre les inégalité
on parlait tout à l'heure de la lutte
contre la fin et les inégalités au
Brésil je crois qu'il aura au cœur de
porter ça à l'échelle internationale et
moi je crois un axe France-Brésil je
pense qu'avec le retour de l'Ola c'est
un intérêt pour la France et le
président Macron je crois va bientôt
aller au Brésil et je crois que ça c'est
positif pour les Français c'est positif
aussi pour l'Europe même s' a la
question de l'accord mercosour Union
européenne qui très dur temps sera l'un
des sujets internationaux de loua et où
on va être en tension nous autres
français européens Loula 77 ans
aujourd'hui on n' pas non plus
l'occasion de d'évoquer ce qui pourrait
succéder à Loula on le fera peut-être à
l'occasion d'une prochaine émission
merci beaucoup en tout cas tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat doc
aujourd'hui vos réactions hashtagdbat
doc bien entendu merci à Salma sali qui
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission comme
elle l'accoutumé et je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à
[Musique]
bientôt